in this lesson we're going to talk about
how to write the equation of a line
given a graph so this is something they
test you on on the a c t let's go
through how to do it here basically what
you want to know is the slope intercept
form of the line so y equals mx plus b
is called the slope
intercept form of the line because the m
is the slope
that's the angle of the line and the b
is the y intercept that's where it
intercepts or crosses the y axis so
here you can see that the slope is also
written as the rise over the run the
rise is the vertical direction the run
is the horizontal direction or you can
use the formula y2 minus y1 over x2
minus x1 the difference in the ys gives
you the rise the difference in the x's
give you the run and this is what you
would do if you had two coordinates or
two points that are on the line
point one is x one y one point two is x
two y two you just have to substitute
and solve for the slope so let's look at
a couple of typical examples here see if
you can solve these on your own find the
equation and then we'll go through them
together
okay so the first one
you can see that it's crossing the y
axis at one two three four so if we look
at our equation of our line y equals mx
plus b we know right away that b is
positive four now for the slope we can
do this a couple different ways one way
is we can say let's see what the rise
would be to get from this point to this
point well we can see we're going down
four okay and we're going
right
positive 3. so this is going to be
negative 4 3 x
so our equation is going to be y equals
negative 4 3 x plus 4. now if you don't
like doing it that way the other way to
do it is to look at the coordinates of
each of these points this is 3 0
this point is 0 4 and what we're going
to do is we're going to do our slope
formula so y 2 minus y 1 so that's 0
minus 4 over x 2 minus x 1 that's 3
minus 0
that's negative 4 over 3 and there's our
slope right there okay let's look at
another example
so this one here you can see the y
intercept is at one two three four again
so we have y equals mx plus four
and
the slope looks like we're going from
this point to this point because we're
rising one and running two so we're
going up one over two so that's a slope
of positive one-half so that's the
equation of our line now
if this line was going down to the right
that has a negative slope it's going up
to the right that's a positive slope if
it's horizontal like this right here
then it has a zero slope
and horizontal lines are just y equals
lines so this line would be y equals
three if it was a vertical line like
this it has an undefined slope vertical
lines are going to be x equals lines
this would be x equals negative 3. so
this is uh just a review of how to get
the equation of a line
given the graph definitely an important
concept to know for the act